now I'm going to talk through some of
the graphs to do with this because this
is a big deal I'm just gonna introduce
the idea and then a Friday we'll go into
a little more depth okay so we'll start
from simple I go as far as I can until
hotel guys and then that'll be the ideas
that I'm gonna build on a Friday okay so
let's begin start simple you're gonna
have to draw along with me okay
y equals absolute value of X this is as
simple as it gets right now you can
think about this two ways or more than
two ways but at least two ways based on
the definitions that I gave you the
first time toward that absolute value so
it said first what you can think about
it is just take the positive value that
was the most basic definition I gave
okay so therefore you say well this is
like y equals x and I know what that
looks like but you just take the
positive x right so he's like with X hey
guys good ol y equals x some of it is
positive so no problems okay that part's
all happy times but on the left-hand
side I have a whole portion the graph
that is negative all right so instead I
make that part positive right so most
people learn about absolute value graph
says oh yes the bouncy things right
because they come down to the axis and
then they literally bounce okay that's
not that complicated all right let's
think about a couple of variations on
this let's think about first let's
modify it within the absolute value sign
so if I said well how would this thing
be different okay so we've looked at
this before briefly again I'm gonna go
to this idea or think about well what
does X minus 1 look like okay and it's
just like expert drop-down and then
again I think well I just want the
positive parts so this bits good and
this bit is not okay now this is a
really important point under Ashley's
diagraphs I'm gonna put this on both of
them because what you've got is two
branches that are behaving completely
differently they in fact have different
equations and we knew this based on our
definition from
for the absolute value of x means two
things at two different places when X is
negative the absolute value of x is
negative x and when X is positive it's
just a regular old X okay and these two
these two are the equations of my two
branches right
there's minus X and there's X now
exactly the same way and you don't need
to keep on writing it out in this formal
way you can start to see it right here's
the unmodified part what's the equation
of the unmodified pot it's just X minus
one okay
the part that we flipped we just slapped
a minus sign on right
see yeah I've just thought that - I know
so the effect that that has is just
turning it around right because if we
minus X plus one which is the same as
well that's that okay
what happens if the modification the
shift is outside of the absolute value
so if I get an answer evaluate and then
take away one okay well I'm gonna think
about this thing cuz I've got the
absolute value of X right there and then
this minus one it just brings the whole
thing down the whole thing okay so
you'll be careful because even though we
say oh yes absolute value graphs they
bounce and they always bounce at the
axis will they bounce it the actress if
you're gonna have to do that around the
whole thing all right but here I have an
absolute value and then I take that and
then I bring it down like so it's gonna
look like this okay okay because of
course if I actually substitute a value
like say 0 into this it'll become y
equals the absolute value 0 which is
still 0 and then you take away 1 so it's
an absolute value graph but it does have
negative components to it okay now again
I can write out the equations of these
two lines it's going to match this for
that pot right but what's the equation
of the left-hand Rotch
it's gonna be the negative case of this
right so it'll be minus X minus one that
minus ones outside the absolute value it
doesn't get flipped around can you see
that and you can verify it because you
like minus X gradients going down and
the intercept is negative one thumbs up